now let me do a brief addendum to the
Donald Trump UN General Assembly speech
this is just a short little thing I
mentioned earlier that Donald from
speech in terms of its tone was very
bizarre in terms of its content it was
disgusting but it was also so low-energy
that Donald Trump's cabinet secretary
Wilbur Ross the Commerce Secretary slept
through the speech now Wilbur Ross has
slept through speeches before he's in
his 80s he may just be a really tired
guy take a look at this video for the
same reason we have pursued ball
diplomacy on the Korean Peninsula i've
told kim jonghwan what i truly believe
that like iran his country is full of
tremendous untapped potential if you
were merely listening and not watching
as donald trump did that extremely low
energy a teleprompter reading Wilbur
Ross was visibly sleeping and again
there are reports out from months ago
about Wilbur Ross generally sleeping
through meetings pretty frequently so
this isn't new but yet just you know the
the entire big picture of it Trump in
the most low-energy Downard trump mode
that we've maybe ever seen a cabinet
secretary literally sleeping during it
while the rest of the world watches in
sort of confused
horror about the ridiculous things that
Donald Trump is saying we got to get
this guy out we've got to get him out
by voting in November of 2020 the
impeachment inquiry will not lead to a
Senate conviction of Trump we've got to
get him out because it's just
embarrassing it is embarrassing to be a
citizen or resident of a country where
this guy is the president and even
Wilbur Ross unable to stay awake for it